I said okay you guys keep saying all
this stuff is real you keep saying
you've got high quality data that you
can't show anybody because it's all
stove pipe you hear this word over and
or stovepipe meaning that each little
group is isolated like Bob Lazar says
yeah I was only allowed to see this
little thing
so I say okay am I right that you're
telling me that these things are real
yeah and then they say and that nobody
could do this that we know of I said
that's right because they seem to defy
the laws of physics you hear this phrase
over and again
I said great I need to talk to somebody
who speaks physics how do you know they
defy physical law
well we can see that they do it's like
okay if they defy physical law
then there should be a physicist to tell
me that they defy physical law who's
seeing the data maybe he can't release
it to me or she
but
tell me somebody who speaks tensor
analysis tell me somebody who knows what
the Dirac equation is like a pretty low
Bar for a physicist
there is no one
and I don't quite mean no one but you
know who Eric W Davis is no
you ever heard of the Wilson memo no
okay there's something called the Wilson
memo where there's a physicist who meets
a general or an admiral and the general
the Admiral is trying to figure out I
think this is an EG and G
um why is there some program that I'm
not allowed to know about I have the
highest clearances I have a need to know
like sorry we can't tell you
he's talking to somebody named Eric W
Davis
Eric W Davis
so far as I can find is the only person
other than maybe Hal put off
who I've been able to talk to who speaks
anything of these languages
this is not a particularly famous
physicist
Hal put off as an electrical engineer I
think PhD in electrical engineering
Eric W Davis says to me I said is there
nobody out here who speaks physics this
doesn't make any sense
and he says well you Hal and I are the
three most technical people on this Joe
I'm not even on this
so you know as much about it as anyone
and you're not even involved and there's
only two other people that know the
science and like one of them is into
remote viewing and
and was a Scientologist
um so
I'm just imagine that you take your wife
to the symphony okay you're gonna see
Beethoven seventh and you look at the
string section the brass section's in
place and the percussion is there you
look at the string section and it's a
bunch of certified public accountants
anyway
where the vial ends where the viola is
like oh oh no actually that we have
reporters for the AP they're stringers
like that's not the same thing we have
string theorists that's not the same
thing I'm looking for Vine like this is
simple I've been on this for three years
and I can't find anybody who speaks this
language which now that is a huge clue
imagine that you say that we've lost
control of our airspace
we're being menaced uh threats to
civilian Aviation military Aviation
they're seeing these things every day
they defy the physical laws and they're
no physicists anywhere to be found
that smells like BS or it smells like a
pathological level of bureaucratic
incompetence
and Marco Rubio and Kirsten gilderbrand
if you're out there
um can you please find out why there are
no technically competent people on an
area on an area of National Security and
please don't Mumble the word stovepipe
or need to know or sources and methods I
mean we had a Manhattan Project we
staffed it with physicists you have a
physics problem
if these things are here Joe they are
here from so far out of town or they are
co-mingling with us on Earth I can't
tell you which
there are some reports that these things
come screaming in from behind our
satellites that are trained at Earth
along non-ballistic trajectories I have
no idea how to say this I'm talking all
the time to Avi Loeb uh with the Galileo
project trying to help him out he needs
funding and he needs some ability to you
know just if the government won't play
ball he's going to put out his own
sensors in places like Catalina Island
blanket the world and he'll be able to
say we're seeing these things and we're
not seeing these things but right now we
have a puzzle that our government won't
release information to its own
scientific Community it reminds me of
you probably know airplane movie well
this is well there's this point where
they're trying to land this airplane
with these people who aren't Pilots he
says turn on the turn on the landing
strip lights and it was Lloyd Bridges or
somebody says no that's just what
they'll be expecting like he's trying to
sabotage the people who are trying to
land the plane doesn't make any sense
we're sabotaging our own scientists
do you think this is because there's a
level of secrecy that's attached to this
technology and they've compartmentalized
themselves to death and they've gotten
themselves to a point where they don't
know how to proceed further because
they're preventing people from sharing
information which is one of the most
important things about science right is
that scientists get to share information
and all work together to try to figure
out what the problem is is that a
reasonable
well here comes the decision trees like
I wish I could say yeah that's what I
think it is but it might not be so one
possibility is let's be honest
if you are faking UFOs the last people
you want are the world's most brilliant
physicists
you give them the data they're going to
say right oh look I see what you did you
put a couple of flashlights with lasers
into the sky and you can move them
really quickly by the angle and that
creates the illusion that something is
zipping through the world right if you
are faking UFOs if you're faking a UFO
gasm the last thing you want is
theoretical physicists on the case so
that would be one reason to clear them
out another reason would be bureaucracy
you've got these rival groups they're
all starved for money nobody wants to
invite somebody smarter than they are so
the problem with a B level in c-level
players is that they're looking for dnf
players so that they're not threatened
that's another possibility
a different possibility is that we do
have a Manhattan Project and we don't
know about it so for example we have a
Manhattan project for decoding
cryptographic messages and it's called
The National Security Agency NSA and it
used to be called No Such agency because
we wanted to deny its existence but now
we know it's got a giant building
how do you know that it exists if nobody
told you well you'd look at the number
of number Theory phds
and people who specialize in things like
elliptic curves and you would notice
that a giant number of them after their
phds disappear
and you track to see well where do those
people live where do those names live oh
they live in Virginia okay
so you'd start to get an idea now in the
case of UFOs if there was an
anti-gravity project which is it's like
it's painful for me to even say these
words really what it would be is a
post-einsteinian physics project
if you had a post-einsteinian physics
project you would want three
sub-specialties for sure that would be
differential geometry which is the basis
for
um originally uh general relativity
in 1976 75
two guys named Xian Yang and Jim Simons
who Jim Simons becomes the world's
greatest hedge fund manager
um
figure out that Quantum field theory is
also based on Geometry
but it's a different version of
differential geometry so that's one
specialty that you would want
second specialty that you would want
would be particle theory or high energy
physics
however you want to say that the third
specialty you'd want is general
relativity
so if you wanted to detect whether we
had a Secret Manhattan Project but it
wasn't
identifiable
by a building because we didn't announce
its existence you'd say is there
anything that eats those three
Specialties unless you believe that
there's a secret University system
because we have lists of everybody who
gets produced with a PhD in these fields
if that was the case
the two places that you would have a
secret place would be Austin
which is the successor to The Institute
for field physics at the University of
Texas Austin
gravitational group General relativistic
Group which has had John we Archibald
wheeler Stephen Weinberg
Bryce DeWitt this is a Powerhouse of a
place that you happen to live in and you
should have these people who are the
successors to these people on because
most of these people have died
but the more spectacular place would be
satuck at Long Island
the State University of New York at
Stony Brook
has an astounding collection of Monster
mines
and it's not highly regarded
as a university I mean it's it's strong
but you would have no idea how strong
this place is it's got multiple Fields
medalists
it's got an Institute called the what is
it the center for geometry Simon Center
for geometry and physics CN Yang who's
arguably the greatest living theoretical
physicist uh is at this University is
101 years old so he's he's pretty much
on his way out but this is where he's
called home
and it's not advertised as the
PowerHouse that it is so shout out to
the State University of New York at
Stony Brook if I was going to locate a
Manhattan Project in plain sight and get
U.S news and world this is a minor
player in uh in research that's where
I'd go
but more importantly and this is the
really weird thing and again I don't
want to spread this as a rumor but I am
saying if you wanted to imagine that
there was that the government wasn't
incompetent we actually had great people
on this project
my friend and advisor has now died is
the door singer
once said to me he said the world's
greatest mathematics and physics
department is Renaissance Technologies
I said what didn't make any sense to me
it's great people but it's a hedge fund
okay so you've got this weird thing
where you've got three basic
uh institutions that are very closely
intertwined you've got Brookhaven
National Laboratory
you've got State University of New York
at Stony Brook a mid-level university
with an out of this world math and
physics program
and you've got a hedge fund that makes
more money than anybody can possibly
imagine
like there's no there used to be four
Fortunes in hedge funds that didn't make
any sense
one was de Shaw one was Bernie Madoff
one was Jeff Epstein and one was
Renaissance Technologies
whoa
and I guessed that Bernie Madoff was
front header legitimate business and an
illegitimate business and he was
front-running the legitimate business
with his illegitimate business so he was
effectively stealing from his own
clients in two separate division in one
division one one was the theft one was
the dupes
I got that wrong he was just running a
Ponzi scheme so shame on me
but I was giving talks about you know
there's black rock and black